So supposed this is
some example data and
we are going to create a bunch
of one nearest neighbor models.
We first have to select, randomly, some
of our data, to go into the first bag.
So I'm going to circle
some of theses points,
randomly, that represent
our first model.
So we randomly selected
some of these points.
Now let's show what
that model looks like.
So this zigzagging orange line here
represents what that one nearest
neighbor model would look like.
And, yes,
to me it looks like it's overfitting.
But that's just our first model.
Then we draw some more data,
and we have another model.
So our other model, Model 2,
is somewhat overfitting as well.
Well, let's consider
now a ensemble model
where we combine
the results of these two.
And at each point where we query,
remember what we do is we take
the mean of the two models.
So, you can see already,
as this blue curve is a bit more smooth.
And the individual models,
we're beginning to get something better.
But let's add some more models.
So I've drawn over here a couple
more one nearest neighbor models.
And you can see each one of them
individually as sort of over fit.
But if we now sample at each
individual spot across here and
take the average across all of them we
get something that's much more smooth.
So here's what our ensemble looks like.
And as you can see,
it's much more smooth.
Of course, I hand drew it.
So you could accuse me
of smoothing it by hand.
[LAUGH] Anyways, the point here
is that you can build an ensemble
that is much more smooth than any of
the individual learners by themselves.